>> NORTH: Now we're going to spend about half
an hour talking about the details of the Wave
data model and how that sort of--the various
layers of the obstruction that we have. This
will help you understand how Wave works, the
system. And also if you dive into the code,
what are some of the various things they're
doing in there. I think that the changing
time zone is catching up with me so I'm sorry
if my voice is starting go. But I'll stay
in the microphone. Can everyone still hear
me okay at the back of the room at the moment?
Yeah, nods, all right. What's up? All right,
I think it was the feedback. All right, so
I'm going to do it in a kind of bottom up
way. I'm going to start at the bottom with
the sort of the most basic components and
build up the out-layers of obstruction so
you can see where we're going. So to start
with the--you won't see anything to do with--well,
the word, "blip" won't appear for quite a
while and it's a good thing. Okay, so wave
documents you probably at least roughly familiar
with. So wave document is a structured rich
text document. We use an XML-like tree structure
for the content of the document. If you look
at a document in sort of one of our debug
output or something it looks very much like
XML, it's probably a subset of XML. You could
pass it with an XML passer. It's not strictly
XML and that we don't--it doesn't conform
to various XML standards. And there's lots
of stuff you can put in XML that you can't
put in wave documents. And the reason--it
looks like XML because it's very convenient,
it maps an IC to a browser DOM for rendering.
But lots of the way data is represented in
Wave is very much governed by its need to
behave well under operational transform and
so arbitrary XML doesn't behave well under
operational transform it's difficult to get
concurrent behavior to resolve nicely. And
so we arrived at the structure that I'll talking
about after sort of number of iterations of
different models to arrive at one that sort
of preserves intense naturally under operational
transform. So, we use an XML tree-like structure
for the structural content. And then we have
stand-off annotations for styling information
and metadata about the document. And so these
are not something that you find in XML and
they don't--they're not part of the structure
of the document. So we'll talk about each
of these in a bit of detail. The document
structure here this is what a document that's
representing a blip, a message, looks like
inside Wave. So you can see it's tree-structured
with a body as kind of a top level tag. We
have line tags and gadget tags and there's
a few other tags that you can find inside
a blip document. We have schemas that define
what can go in here but the schema is one
item of Wave's data model that needs a lot
of work. The schemas are not currently enforced
in Wave in a Box and they're currently represented
in Java code rather than any kind of declarity
of the--in declarative way. And so schema
is something we have some time for discussion
later on in the week about what we should
be doing with schemas, and you know, how we
can do it better. All right, so this is an
example of a wave document. It looks like
XML but it's not exactly like XML. If anyone
spot anything that's a bit weird about this
document that you wouldn't do naively?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: Yeah, so they're only...
>> NORTH: You're right, on the second and
third lines, the content, the words, "wave
summit," and who's coming to the summit are
not nested inside the line elements; it's
after end of the line element. And that's
an arrangement we arrived at--after a bit
of experimentation and lot's of code and the
reason we do that is for operational transform.
So it turns out to be very, very difficult
to build operation components and the right-correct
intention-preserving transformation code if
you put the content inside the line element.
If two people concurrently on different computers,
you know, on the other side of the world both
carriage-return inside this nested element
you need to sort of--sorry, you're probably
familiar with HTML. If you hit carriage return
inside the--inside a PL in an HTML, what you
want is basically the insert, a slash P and
then a P. It's the point where you hit carriage
return so you then have two paragraphs. If
two people do that concurrently inside the
same paragraph that's not too hard to resolve.
If someone presses backspace over, one of
those sort of breaks, you want the paragraphs
to merge, it becomes a trickier to resolve
with someone also is splitting it at the same
point or a different point. And we also want
to be able to undo these operations, have
inverts--inversion of all these operations
so you can undo your changes when you are
doing things. And so the operational transform
code to handle this kind of thing blew out
and we never correctly implemented it despite
a lot of trying. Until eventually we decided,
"Oh, if we just put the text outside of the
line elements the problem goes away." Now,
with two people on this line here want to
break the line at two different points you
just--in here and here, concurrently they
can insert the line/line pair and a line/line
pair here, and that's just a really easy transformation
that's just two insertions. And there's no
sort of--and if someone else's is backspacing
over them it all just resolves nicely. And
so we can write it correctly. We can do lots
of testing to sort of almost prove. We should
be able to theoretically prove it but we don't
have a mathematical proof at all if the transform
is correct. So that that's one example of
solving an unnatural--it doesn't look like
the way you would na誰vely represent it in
an XML but it behaves much, much better under
operational transform. Sorry. And again, please
stick your hand up if you have any questions
throughout this talk. Yeah?
>> Do you guys--you mentioned [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: We thought about it and there's
a few different ways you can think about embedding
tables in Wave. It is work that we sort of
had underway. I think, actually, Dan might
have dumped a bunch of the code that would
halfway to do it. He said he was about to.
We've got a bit of a way towards implementing
it.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: I think there probably isn't. But
I think we were trying to dig it out. It wasn't
fully functional what we've started putting
some of the building box in place. Sorry,
the question for the rest of the Internet
was whether there's any support for tables.
And that's another good example of the data
model. It doesn't just map directly into Wave.
If you just put an HTML table inside Wave,
the transform of people adding rows and columns
to the table is horrible. But we do have a
sort of more indirect mechanism of doing it
and we will work in towards that. Yeah?
>> Along the same lines of [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Question was that, "Is there any
way to split a video or images?" So we have
a basic embedding of images. So there's an
image thumbnail. It was an image tag which
works of it like image tag in HTML it refers
to, or refers to an attachment ID or URL,
do these both. There's one that refers to
a URL frame, it's like an HTML tag. And there's
one that refers--excuse me, to an image that's
attached to a wave as an attachment. If you
saw the Wave demo you can sort of drop photos
in a wave and that sort of attached to it
like email attachments are. And you can refer
to them from an element inside the wave as
well. Video, again, not naively but by embedding
a--oh, I can't remember what the tag name
is--gadget, I guess. You can embed a YouTube
video inside a wave by just embedding a YouTube
gadget inside the wave. That doesn't actually
put the video content inside the wave but
it refers to it in the same way that you embedded
it in an HTML page. Okay, so what you don't
find in the XML-style content is a style in
mockups, a style kind of mockup. And so if
we--Wave can support colors and fonts and
headings and all that kind of stuff. But we
don't do it like a na誰ve HTML would do it.
The problem, of course--again, it doesn't
play well with operational transform. If you
have nested pairs of tags, if you want to
mess the bold inside a font tag and someone
hits carriage return in the middle you've
now got a doubly hard a problem just split
them out and resolve concurrently. And, of
course, it's just ugly when you have to munge
the structure of your document to represent
the fact that various style regions overlap,
which is of course how you end up doing it
in your na誰ve HTML before CSS. So, instead,
we use stand-off annotations. And an annotation
sort of paints a region of the document with
a key value pair. And so, down at the bottom
here, I've tried to represent what it looks
like. So, not represented inside the content
of--inside the tree content of the document
but in a separate data structure held next
to it is a set of key value pairs and a region
of the document that they spend, a non-empty
region of the document. And so you--and annotations
can overlap perfectly fine. You can have as
many annotations as many as you like, and
the operational transform is very easy to
get to work for most cases. There's an edge
case that's--is a bit difficult that we ran
and recently fixed. Right, so they can overlap.
So, font styles, colors, head--not heading
types. Heading types are represented as attributes
on an element. And things like the spelling
when the origin is misspelled, the spelling
agent goes and annotates that region with
the--and in cache, if those has been misspelled
and appoint it to some corrections. Question?
>> Won't the annotation of those [INDISTINCT]?
>> NORTH: Oh, there's a dodgy case when you're
deleting at the end of an annotated region
when someone else is deleting or inserting.
It was quite contrived and took a long time
for us to discover it through lots and lots
of randomized testing. I personally bug about
it recently on our bug track I probably didn't
give you quite enough information. Suffice
to say it was a case deepened and transformed
something to do with deleting annotative regions.
Okay, so structure and annotations separately
doing--each doing what it's good at doing
and then each transforms fairly natural. Okay,
I think I went over this. So, they paint a
structural content here. A good way of thinking
about it is a key value but it's painting
some region. So if you delete, delete the
painted region, the annotation is gone there's
nothing for it to paint. If you insert a content
in the middle of an annotated region it is
also annotated it just naturally keeps its
annotation. If you--and it behaves extremely
well concurrently. If you--if there's a paragraph
and someone is typing in the middle of it
and you select the whole paragraph and hit,
"bold," then not only does the paragraph turn
bold but all the characters that they typed
even if they're on the wire somewhere, they've
already type them, they still end up bold
in the document as it comes out. Thanks to
the transform. They also--we have an inheriting
scheme for annotations. So if there's a region
of text that has some annotation and you insert
another character at the very end of that
region it inherits the annotation of the item
to what's left of the annotations. So, again,
if you're--again, this is a bit of a tradeoff,
but the good side of the tradeoff is if you're
typing it at the end of a paragraph that's
styled with some font you don't have to keep
sending the same annotations with each character.
You just send the characters that you're sending
and they naturally inherit the annotation
values from the character to their left. Questions?
Okay. You should--it's certainly on Google
Wave. You can get a look at the--oh, sorry,
on a Wave sandbox, you can get a look at the
annotations and the structure of a document
by looking at the edited debug menu. I think
it's only visible on Wave sandbox. But that
shows you some of the content of what your
blip documents look like. So just briefly
then on operations, much of this is being
covered in other talks at the various Google
I/Os and so on so I'm not going to go too
deeply into the operations and the transform.
But in brief, an operation is a function of
document state that transforms a document
from one state to the next. An operation instructed
is as a sequence of components so the operation
streams are over the document and applies
mutations to the document as it streams over
it. So, the basic mutation is retained which
is to not mutate so you can sort of retain
a bunch of characters that are already in
the document as they are. Then you can insert
and delete characters, insert and delete elements,
the--what you know as external tags, start/end.
Then, of course, by the end of the--by--a
whole operation has to preserve the nesting
of the well form and nest of the structure.
Update and replace attributes on elements
or an element like a line element can have
an attribute on it. So, for example, headings
are represented by an attribute that's placed
on the line element and that marks that whole
line as a heading. Much the same way as you
might have, yeah, heading tag in a--well,
it probably won't have a dedicated tag, it's
just a type of line. And then annotation boundaries.
So annotation boundary is just saying you're
at this point this key becomes this value.
And then at some point there needs to be another
annotation boundary that says, "All right,
this annotation has ended," and that defines
a painted region. So graphically then, down
at the bottom here there's these two operations.
The way to interpret this graphic is that
each horizontal line is a document state.
So the document starts out in this--in this--in
this state represented by this line and the
operation is the space between the horizontal
lines. And so a white box here is just a retain
component that says, "Just keep this part
of the document as is." Then a red component
is a--some deletion or deletion of either
characters or elements. And so you can see
this region collapses out of the document
when this operation is applied. Then over
here, this green triangle is an insertion
component. And so as this component of the
operation is applied, content is inserted
in the middle. And so then this diagram shows
two operations. So you can see two operations
can take the document through a series of
states. And, you know, the components can
overlap in here. Part of the inserted content
is deleted in the next--the next component
of the operation. Wave operations are composable,
which means for any pair of operations like
this, you can collapse them into one operation
which represents the same mutation and then
out with any number of operations. They can
all be collapsed, composed into one operation
on--in the domain of a single document. And
this is--this is how we represent our documents.
You know, on disc, the structure of the daughter
end document is purely defined as the sequence
of operations that mutate the empty document
into some state. Operations are also invertible.
So for any operation, you can compute an operation
that does--has the opposite effect when applied
to a document that's sort of in a state after
the first one. You could make that computation
without reference to the document. You only
need an operation to be able to compute its
inverse you don't need reference to the document
it applies to. And they can--and they transform.
So there's three important--three important
properties. They are composable, invertible,
and they transform against each other, which
means the server is able to compute intention
preserving result, intention preserving changes
to operations committed by different clients
at different points in the document. But if
you want more detail about operations, perhaps
chat one of us later or have a look at some
of the Google I/O talks from, I guess, the
2009 ones. They probably have the most detail.
And there are some other videos on YouTube
as well describing this. Are there any questions?
All right. Awesome. Okay, so we jump up a
level. We get to Wavelets. A wavelet is a
collection of documents and a collection of
participants who are participating on that
collection of documents. Let's go from the
top. So a wavelet has an ID. Well, it has
two IDs; a wave ID and a wavelet ID. Both
of these have the form of some domain which
hosts the thing and then some unique pseudo-random
part--unique that identifies it. And a wavelet
has two IDs. One, which identifies the wave
it's in, and one which identifies it within
the wavelet. Then as a bunch of participants,
all the participants share the wavelet equally
in a funny na誰ve case. So if you are a participant
on a wavelet, you can view and mutate anything
in the wavelet. Access control is something
we build on top of this layer. It's then just
a bag of documents. The documents have identifiers.
The identifiers are frequently structured
so there's a special document that's named,
"Conversation," which I'll talk about a bit
later. These documents--each message in a
wave conversation is backed by one document.
There's also other documents that implement
other sort of aspects of a conversational
wave like the tags that are applied to it.
So they're--these are all represented inside
documents. They're all mutated by document
ops. They're not special things in the protocol.
Everything is just wavelets which are bags
of documents. So the two operations that apply
to a wavelet are to add and remove participants
and then to just apply an operation to some
document that's part of the wavelet. And so,
wavelets are nothing else that's special.
Questions? Cool. Okay, a wave then--finally,
we're up to the level where we can talk about
what a wave is, that's nothing more than a
collection of wavelets. It's not a question
that's explicitly stored anywhere. It's simply
the set of wavelets that share a wave ID.
So a wave is added--a wavelet is added to
a wave simply by giving it a wave ID of that
wave. And this means that a wave is not necessarily
hosted even on one service provider. So we
could have a wave on acmewave.com, and someone
else on the federated Wave sandbox.com could
add a wavelet to that wave, perhaps representing
a private reply, and only add Wave sandbox.com
participants to that wavelet, and Acmewave
would never see that wavelet. It's still logically
part of the wave but Acmewave only has a partial
view of it in this case. I mean, so that the
daughter of that private reply on Wave sandbox
never travels across near the incident to
Acmewave. You don't even need to trust Acmewave
at all to be able to have a wave--a wavelet
that's part of that wave. Yeah, question?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: That's right. The only reason it
would find out is if someone who does know
that it exists adds an Acmewave participant,
and then the Wave sandbox, the Wave sandbox
server, will tell Acmewave that the wavelet
exists and you should go and fetch the data.
But normally, outside a federation, you know,
most of the wavelets in a wave are hosted
on one machine and you can just sort of--just
scan of the data stores and so on to discover
which wave looks a part of the same wave.
Okay. So then we also have a concept that's
not stored anywhere but represented in a running
way system which is a Wave view. And that's
one user's--one client's view of the wavelets
in a wave that it participates on. So a wave
might have a bundle of wavelets. Some of them
might be shared by lots of people. Some of
them might be private wavelets that only has
only one participant. A client's view is the
wavelets where that client's, you know, address
participates on that wave. And so in the code,
it's the client front end which computes the
client's view. It has access to the wave person,
sees all the wavelets. It computes the client's
view and sends only the deltas that are in
view to a particular client. Any questions?
We're cool. All right. So what I've described
up till now is what we think of as the core--the
sort of the core of Wave. It's an attempt
to be an application diagnostic tool bag of,
you know, concurrent documents with participation
upon which application models can be built.
And the application model which everyone is
familiar with is the conversation which is,
of course, the one it was originally designed
for. So a conversation then is an abstract
data model that we embed in this--in this
substrate of wavelets and documents. So the
way a conversation is represented is there's
one document per blip, so one document per
conversational message. There's another document
which describes the--describes the--yeah,
the structure of the blips; which blips are
replies to which, which blips are in which
threads, and how those things are nested within
the wavelet. And so it's described inside
the document rather than being sort of represented
deep into the core. And then private replies,
I briefly discussed a separate wavelet. So,
a conversation might have a number of wavelets.
Some of them will be conversational wavelets
that everyone is participating on. Some of
them will be private user on the wavelets
that only--normally have only one participant
on them and they contain sort of your metadata
about the conversation. And some might be
private replies which are conversational but
are only shared with the subset of the participants.
So I can talk a little bit about how that
nesting happens. So there's a special document
inside each conversational wave called conversation,
and here's an example of one. And it describes
the nesting of threads and messages. So there's
an implicit root thread in the conversation.
And then this root thread has two blips; the
one right at the top and the one right at
the bottom. And then there's a reply to that
first blip. Someone near--in the wave client,
like, quick--hit--like, clicked on the first
blip and hit "Reply", and that spawns a new
thread and that thread has two blips as well.
So these two. And then this blip again has
a reply, and there's just a single message
inside that. I should really have had a slide
that shows you what the wave panel looks like
with this conversation but I didn't do that.
So that model is the conversation is a thread,
a thread has a number of blips, and each blip
can have threads and a thread has blips and
so on, mutually, recursively. And then that
give us--that gives us the threaded conversations
that make--a part of what makes Wave useful.
So the flow then to--when you hit, you know,
"Reply," in your Wave client. Your Wave client
first goes and sticks in some, you know, body
tag and an empty line in some new document
that invents. It picks a new document in,
it sticks and empty line in it. And then it
comes along to the conversation manifest and
sticks a new entry in the right point here
describing where that new blip appears in
the conversational structure. And so--and
then the reverse process when someone else--when
some other client receives those mutations.
It sees an empty line up here in some new
document ID, but it doesn't know what that
is yet, and then it sees an entry up here
in the conversation manifest and goes, "Ah,
there's a new blip," and renders it and then
goes and looks up that document for the content.
Okay, any questions about this so far? Yes?
>> [INDISTINCT] have example where you have
a private conversation and a private [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: I don't have any one on screen but
I can describe how that's represented as well.
So a private reply is another wavelet, it
has its own conversation document like this
that describes the structure of each conversation.
The difference being that the conversation
element, sort of, the top level element of
its manifest, also it describes a point in
the parent conversation where it's embedded.
So our current code--our current code, I think,
describes the message that it's in a reply
to so it identify a blip ID of the reply,
but I don't think it appropriately yet describes
where. So you can do--oh, we can't do inline
reply, that's right. You can't do inline private
replies yet. All right, so attributes on the
conversation element. There is a reply wavelet
ID which says, "This wavelet is a private
reply to some other wavelet," then a reply
blip ID which says--and within that wavelet
the blip with this identifier is the one that
this is a reply to. So each private reply
wavelet is its own wavelet, has its own manifest
describing the layout of blips and references
by name where it should appear in its parent
conversation. This has the effect that there's
no trace of the private reply in the parent
conversation. Someone who doesn't participate
on it cannot know that it exists, let alone
see the content. Yeah?
>> How do you identify it with where it goes
[INDISTINCT]?
>> NORTH: Just by identifier. So it's--a private
reply is always in reply to some blip. So
that blip has an ID and we just name that
ID in this wavelet conversation manifest.
At the moment we can't describe it with any
more precision than in a reply to this message.
Did that make sense? Not quite? Let's chat
it out again later. Yeah?
>> How popular was private replies to a lot
it can do?
>> NORTH: Do you know the steps are?
>> And, maybe. If you would, did you have
[INDISTINCT] how many if you will use [INDISTINCT]?
>> [INDISTINCT] made public but very small.
>> Yeah.
>> Very, very small.
>> NORTH: It was pretty small.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: It probably scaled a bit with, sort
of, how happy you were--technically savvy,
it was not in the most discoverable feature.
It was not immediately obvious how they work
either, so.
>> These people were just [INDISTINCT] in
a way at that time anyways, so.
>> NORTH: So they're not widely used. I don't
think Wave in a Box supports them right now
but, you know, we'll work towards it. It didn't
seem like a blocker for us having something
working. Yeah?
>> If the private reply references blip in
the parent conversation.
>> NORTH: Yeah?
>> Will this delete it? What happens to the
entire reply?
>> NORTH: The question was if the private
reply reference is a blip and that blip is
deleted, what happens? The private reply is
basically often the client picks somewhere
to attach it, you know, probably at the very
bottom of the wave or something. It's still
there but we don't know where to point it
anymore. So, I guess, a trade off of the fact
that there's no trace of it in the parent
wavelet is that the--someone who doesn't know
about its existence can't fix that up. What's
next? Okay. So the conversation is one of
these models that we embed on top of the wave
core model. Other things that we embed, tags.
So in Google Wave each wave has a bunch of
tags; tags are shared. The tags each represented
in another document inside the wavelet, the
document is called tags. And it's just, basically,
it looks like a list of XML structure elements
called tag with a value if it's the value
of tag. So we embed--we represent this list
of, you know, arbitrary data that's attached
to a conversation just in another document.
Per use of data, so every--on Google Wave,
I don't know if they're live on Wave in a
Box yet. I don't know if it's quite been hooked
up yet. Each user has a bunch of data about
their interaction with a wave. So when you
view a wave we keep track of, you know, which
messages you have viewed. So when you coma
back you can see a, you know, a green light
marking messages they didn't use since when
we looked at it. And we can track when you
hit the archive button to make the wave go
away until it, you know, is changed again
or when you put in it in a folder. All that
is sort of information that's only--that's
private to you. It's your interaction with
the wave it's not shared with other people.
But we also store that, you know, in Wave
and so the way that works is another wavelet
which we call your user data wavelet. I mean,
it has an ID which includes your address so
it's sort of you can--the ID is well-known
to you so you can look it up. You are the
only participant on it so it just never gets
sent to other clients at all; it's not in
their view. It never gets federated because
there's no one from federated service who
participates in it. And so it represents folders
in the read state and in which things you've
seen and read which--and you can unmarked
things as unread whether you've got something
in a folder or so on. All inside data structures
that are embedded inside another wavelet inside
the wave that only you can see. So I'm not
going to show you all of the ways they're
variously embedded. There's code--there's
code which is in the repository which describes
ways to embed basic data structures like lists
and maps inside wave documents. And Dave Hern
is going to talk about that on Wednesday morning,
I think, a bit more about how you can embed
your own data structure inside wave's document
model. Folders, archive, follow--yeah, okay,
so all of those things.
>> So, Alex...
>> NORTH: Yeah?
>> If you were to gather 100,000 users reading
the same document and they point some archive...
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> ...the opposite, actual stores in way on
a server grows to accommodate those individual
states, all 100,000 users?
>> NORTH: Yes, the question was if you have
hundreds of thousands--excuse me, hundreds
of thousands of people all watching the same
wave, does the state on the server grow to,
you know, in scale with that? And the answer
is, yes. Each of them ends up with the user
data wavelet, but normally pretty small. It's
like a couple of documents, but, yes, it grows.
If you of course--yeah. The answer is yes.
If you didn't have that, I'm not trying to
excuse it, but if you didn't have that, of
course, you would be storing the data in some
other data store or somewhere else.
>> You know it might be interesting just to
think about [INDISTINCT] work for the [INDISTINCT]
in a way to distribute the documented state.
You know, that if you only store the data
for the users that are directly [INDISTINCT]
to store that [INDISTINCT]?
>> NORTH: So
the question was can federation be used to
sort of spread that--spread that load a bit?
And the answer is, yes, at least in a way.
If you have a wave and it has lots of participants
from other federated servers on it, the server
hosting the conversational wavelet that doesn't
host the user data, their own wave servers
host it. Their own user data wavelets and
never federate--and never federated with you
because no one users on your server participates.
So if you--if you have lost of federated users
then, yeah, their own service providers host
their own user data so that does spread it
a little bit.
>> So note that the different wavelets within
the same wave are not sort of a transaction
or a unit or something like that so they don't
need to be hosted by the same server. If you
have a multi-server data store then you can
choose to sort of shot this so that the user
data is--are used that a way with this is
hosted on another machine and the conversation
wavelet that it belongs to.
>> So you're saying including the documents
itself would that be a way?
>> So you would have--you would want to put
like one wavelet in this--in one place because
there's one transaction unit, but there are
many waves--so many used data wave that's
in one wave. There are all different wavelets
and you can choose to have them hosted in
different storage package.
>> That would then--so I'm assuming you're
talking about a distributed versus centralized
storage provider?
>> NORTH: Uh-hmm.
>> What happens if one of the distributed
notes falls off? [INDISTINCT] distributed
notes you can't actually recover the wavelets
from there.
>> [INDISTINCT] if the company [INDISTINCT]
that wave service has a repeat [INDISTINCT]
on
it when they only have that it's certainly
one machine...
>> Yes.
>> That's the problem with their architect.
>> Yeah, but if they're talking about a distributed
wave storage [INDISTINCT] which takes out
a couple of wavelet. All of a sudden you're
missing a wavelet when you throw--throwing
errors.
>> You don't--you don't throw all eggs in
a basket.
>> So they should be sinking their ships then?
>> [INDISTINCT] machine?
>> So the...
>> The architectural issue that's outside
of this scope of design of wave.
>> Well, waves at the moment is essential
as all [INDISTINCT].
>> Wave in a Box is--if that code is written
on the work on one server. The core concepts
don't requires that it will be on one business
server. Google is listing their wave on one
server.
>> Yeah, so, I think we are still progressing
off the topic here but I'm happy to explain
how we organize that.
>> NORTH: Yeah, that machine is full all the
time and obviously we didn't--didn't lose
too much data. Right. Okay, now I'm going
to talk--so that's the concept. We had the--right
at the bottom are documents which are mutated
by operation--oh, sorry. Question, yeah?
>> So does the combination of [INDISTINCT]
to look for any other models on [INDISTINCT]
models that [INDISTINCT] composition?
>> NORTH: The composition is the main one.
These metadata-type models that are related
to the conversation are another one. We've
explored a few other ones but didn't sort
of get them done. In some--there are some
things that the wave model is not good for
and there are some that it is good for.
>> Spreadsheet?
>> NORTH: Yes, our tables don't--sorry, spreadsheet
is like a table. We definitely went through
a lot of conceptual thinking about it but,
you know, it didn't--it wasn't--we didn't
implement anything. See a table structure
looks unnatural inside a wave, but it still
ends up being very highly concurrences on.
We have good sort of best practices for embedding
data structures that we sort of developed
and hope to communicate with you over these--the
next few days, but I can't point to anything
else concrete.
>> Suggest [INDISTINCT] wavelets.
>> NORTH: Suggest wavelets? Do people even
know how they are supposed to work?
>> [INDISTINCT] I think--I think that they
are operational [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Yeah, okay.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: Yup, sure. Okay. So in Google Wave
when you type in, you know, start a new wave,
type some content in and so when I hit the
add participant button, Google Wave tries
to be very smart about who appears at top
of that list by analyzing the content and
content you've shared with other users inside
wave. And the way it communicates to you what
the participant's suggestion should be is
through another wavelet. There's another wavelet
in the wave that has a rank to ordering of
participants.
>> Per user?
>> NORTH: Per--yes, per user. So, it's inside
your user data wavelets so no one else sees
your suggestions. Another one which occurs
to me is spelling corrections. So, when you
have to spell each inside the conversation
there's another document that our spelling
agent writes which has a bunch of--has one
entry per misspelled word in the conversational
content. In the conversational content, the
spelling agent annotates a misspelled region
and gives it some ID which is a look up into
the corresponding spell document and then
that contains, you know, a list of suggestions
with your rank orderings and scores and so
on.
>> It's the attachment of data docs as the
upload progresses.
>> NORTH: Oh yeah, attachments is another
one. So, an attachment like an image that
you attach to a wave, the actual binary data
is, you know, your blob stored somewhere,
but the metadata describing it is in another
document. These are what we all what we call
data documents. Documents that are not blip
documents we tend to call data documents and
that has a sort of a record structure embedded
in it that describes the file name, the percentage
that's uploaded. So, that's sort of live updates
as the attachment uploads, the mime type and
stuff like that. So, it's a very simple sort
of record structures are very easy to embed.
Yes?
>> Can you spell the--Wave in a Box go big?
How can a user have standard set of pages
and invite every conversations without having
to ask specifically [INDISTINCT]? So like
spelling, you have to add, it's already there.
What type of the user basically defined the
row instead of agents summarized that are
always present?
>> NORTH: So, right now, Wave in a Box lacks
that. The question was how can users of Wave
in a box have things like spelling that sort
of act on/or waves. Right now, Wave in a box
doesn't have that functionality. Someone mentioned
earlier, I think it was James, that there
was this agent's concept in sort of the early
versions that we've been taking up. It was
not, not well implemented. So, an agent like
spelling sits on the wave bus. In Wave in
a Box, this is all inside one process. In
Google Wave, the wave bus was actually on
the wire, and everything that was in that
original box was on separate machines. So,
the answer is to expose something like the
wave bus as a, you know, as a network level
interface, and then build some--let's call
them agents--which respond to that wave bus
and receive all the data in their trusted
components of your system. They're not things
that you let people need to hook up to. So,
Wave in a Box will--lacks that at the moment.
It's--we need to sort of--we need to rethink
how we can expose a wave bus appropriately
in Wave in a Box. But it's sort of--it's a
little bit beyond our goals in a box because
once we're doing that, it's not--it starts
to become a distributed system. It's something
we want to look at after we get the core thing
working. So, we haven't here done it yet.
>> What was the question? Sorry, I haven't
heard.
>> Oh, in that case, like, spelling. Yeah,
you act on [INDISTINCT] always without the
user having to add a specific [INDISTINCT].
Perhaps, it's an advantage, you know.
>> NORTH: So, right now, you could do it by
coding it into the box--Wave in a Box. But
that's, you know, it's going to be not a winning
game if we do it too many--too often and have
too much stuff running inside there. So really,
the right solution is to--once we have sort
of Wave in a box working and decide we need
to expand it to split out some kind of wave
bus interface over the network and then have
agent like components.
>> [INDISTINCT] your agents that'll be like
too much process then to light on Wave in
a Box.
>> NORTH: Possibly, yeah. I mean, when we
had a library that sort of managed that kind
of stuff we'd probably do it again rather
than try an open source decoder, it wasn't
brilliant.
>> I just got another question here.
>> NORTH: Yeah?
>> I'm really curious in the concepts of theyou
should--you guys manage accounts with the
line, you know, happen to do the line--line
slash line...
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> ...and begin the styling and all that kind
of stuff. And I was wondering when you run
with the same problems you talked earlier
about using Wave to render in something other
than the document.
>> NORTH: Uh-huh.
>> Or possibly render to, for instance, a
lot of drawing on to a map or a PowerPoint
slide or something like that. And would run
into the same process if you were changing
XML into a conversation? It's kind of like
XML on top of XML [INDISTINCT] type it in,
it might going to hit a point where a hit
which results something you've [INDISTINCT]
where your backspace is going.
>> NORTH: The question was, would there be
a problem? Our answer, in the context of my
earlier talking about lines and so on, if
you were trying to type XML into a wave, so
XML to an XML, would you run into sort of
concurrency problems? Probably not. What you
wouldn't have is a guarantee that the XML
is always well formed. Wave documents never
end up in an ill formed state because you
can't apply an operation that breaks the nesting
for example. And it was maintaining that kind
of--those kinds of guarantees that were hard.
If you were just typing XML into a document,
it's not always in a well formed state if
you're, you know, typing and people can be
typing all over the document. And that's fine,
it would look fine.
>> So, I guess the problem then is, you know,
future duration or maybe experimental durations
of Wave. Do we have to have that restriction
of how it will happen to our components?
>> NORTH: The question was should--do we--could
we have a version of Wave that doesn't have
the restriction of being a well formed all
the time? That will be tricky, that requires
deep thought. That's--I mean--so that's built
very deep into the core of Wave that these
documents are well formed. At the top of my
head, it would be a different system if it
wasn't. But it's interesting if you think
about it. I haven't thought about it. Are
there any other questions over here? These
are good questions. I like it.
>> Are there any models you're thinking of
adding?
>> NORTH: Any models we're thinking of adding?
Off the top of my head, no, but it's the kind
of thing where the code is out. It's an off
code right there now that you can, you can
write your own.
>> How do you set it?
>> NORTH: Your settings is another one. The
user settings was--so, if you can turn spelling
on or off or set up email notification and
so on. That was also...
>> Was that a bunch of data documents that
similarly or?
>> NORTH: Yeah. That was a separate wave,
it was your settings wave and a bunch of data
documents.
>> Search as a way or something that you design.
>> NORTH: Oh, yeah. So, currently, the digest,
the search results, your inbox is---well,
let's not talk about how it is currently.
Even in a couple of weeks time it's going
to be on an RPC, you use the data API. So,
it's basically a request response kind of
model. So, what we thought about for a long
time is just putting that in a wave so you
open a wave and the server fills in your inbox
in by embedding it in that wave. And so then,
that sort of gets rid of another--the advantage
of doing that is it gets rid of, you know,
you could get rid of a servelet out of the
server. You can get rid of having--or any
problems with going offline or re-synchronizing
as the wave box--sorry, as the inbox--if you
have a live inbox or the results appear automatically,
you have to invent a new scheme to resolve
the concurrent nature of that. You know, you
can archive something and meanwhile something
appears and those are needed to be resolved
concurrently. You know, Wave just does that
for you so you get to reuse all of that. You
can reuse the handling of the connection going
offline and coming back online and reconnecting
and so on. So, the inbox is one example that
we thought of where we would like to embed
it in a wave. And in fact we have a design
for it, which I have just been sitting on
those. We were planning to do it then we thought,
"No, we'll do something simple first." So
perhaps I'll publish that design when I get
a moment as an example of another thing that
you can embed inside a wave.
>> We've been thinking about sort ofguess
like a search, like a synthetic way where
you're interested in certain things that attach
across multiple ways and you want to just
create this sort of synthetic view and have
it presented more or less.
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> In other ways or something of that nature.
>> NORTH: Yeah, that could work, yeah. All
right, now I'm going to talk a little bit
about the structure of the code that represents
these concepts. So, we've got documents that
are acted on by ops. We have wavelets which
are bundles of documents and then we have
the wave which is this collection of wavelets
and then the abstract models built on top
of that. So, just--for those of you who are--excuse
me going to be going to look inside the code
for this, this is how some of the code modules
are laid out. So, documents first. There's
a raw document down the bottom which you almost
never have to interact with. That's a DOM
data holder state, it has not much smarts,
but it's a DOM--it's a tree structure thing,
very much like an HTML DOM or something. That's
sort of your raw document state, and it's
mutated by, you know, a DOM star API create
child and stuff like that. You always never
have to talk to that; you just need to know
it's there. And then this has two implementations.
There's an implementation in the web client
which has a lot of links into the parallel
HTML DOM. And so as waves change, as operations
are applied and this document mutates, the
editor and rendering engine, mutate the HTML
DOM in parallel. And there's another implementation
for non-browser environments, for service
side environments that just doesn't have those
kind of links. And then most of the smarts
is in index document. Index document maintains
a tree index over the structure of this raw
document. So I can very efficiently jump to
particular locations. It doesn't need to do
a tree traversal, it can jump to particular
locations very fast. And so, it is what ops
apply to. Ops pass things to the index document,
and remember an op is a sequence of these
mutations. The index document that deconstructs
that jumps to the right places in the raw
document and applies the mutations. It does
the consistency checkings, schema checking,
that kind of stuff. And then, events pop out
of the index document as it's changed. So,
a full operation applies and then an event
pops out of the index document describing
what changed as part of that operation. Then
sitting on top of that is what we call a mutable
document. There's a couple of different classes
with various flavors of mutable document.
And these are the ones you will commonly interact
with in code if you're building a data model
on top of a wave or something, and that presents
you a sort of a user-friendly mutation API
so you can create children and insert text
and so on. It's not dissimilar to this API
but an immutable document then generates ops.
Its job is to take your programmatic mutations
and generate an op that describes that and
then apply it to the mutable document that's
beneath it. And the reason we go through that
sort of programmatic and then an op and then
programmatic again is because these ops are,
you know, what Wave is built on and every
ops we need to send all the other serve--send
to the wave server. So, as an op is applied
to this index document it's applied to the
local state. It's also sent out to the remote
server so exactly the same op is applied in
both places. And in the events that come out
of the index document bubble out of the mutable
document as well. And if you're again writing
a data structure, you need to watch what happens
to the document that's representing your data
structure as other people change it. So, it's
a very basic layout of the document. End of
the code. Generally you'll be interacting
with some interface around a mutable document.
Yes?
>> When you're having key strokes, do you
do every key stroke or do you just some sort
of timed key strokes for a certain quantity
of time to exact the operation...
>> NORTH: The bundling is on somewhere slightly
different. The key strokes all are immediately
applied to the local document and produce
an operation. You know, at least as fast as
the browser scheduler let's us do it. But
then we then send an op immediately. They
get bundled up so that we have just one outstanding
request to the server at a time. So, we send
that an op, and then while we're waiting for
the response from the server, we can post
any other ops that are applied to that document.
And when we finally get our response, we send
that composed bundle off as the next--the
next network transaction. So that'll--that
self-throttles according to the network latency.
If you have a high latency connection you
get lots of things composed into one, one
transmission. So this codebin, if you're looking
at a repository it's like an all great particle
wave model document and various sub-packages
of that. A wavelet bin also has a similarly
three-tiered architectural loads wired up
slightly differently. So there's data down
here which includes the documents, that includes
some metadata about the wavelet, like, you
know, the participants, last modified time
stamp, things like that. Again, the things
that we call data are really dumb. They're
just containers. They could almost be a programmatically
generated. They can represent them as a protocol
buffer of something. There's no--there's no
smarts. Ops are applied to the data--or ops
apply themselves to the data via an op executor,
I mean any--and the reason we have this sort
of op executor out to the side is it begin
so we have symmetry with local operations
and remote operations. Local operations are
produced by other bits of coding in--running
in your--in your client and apply to this--this
data. And remote operations at the server
some other client has generated, sent to the
server and now being sent to you, come in
the same way and apply to the same data. And
what that--yeah, I wonder which way I should
describe this. And as the data mutates events
pop out and this event stream propagates up
through the various layers of obstruction.
So above this data layer, we have a classical
op-based wavelet and an op-based blip--or
that shouldn't be called blip. This layer
here takes programmatic mutations and build
ops that describe them and then applies them
to the data upon which it sits. So, again,
data is only over-mutated by operations and
not joined here like it was not joined in
the other one. The ops that pop out of here
are the ops that are sent off to the remote,
remote--it's off to the server to be sent
out to the other clients. So, again, the data
is only ever operated on by ops, and we have
ops from local mutations and remote mutations
follow the same code path once they've been
created. And so the events that pop out of
the data here come up to the op-based wavelet
and then up to your application model, which
is--so the application model might be the
conversation model which sits on top of an
op-based wavelet and sort of interprets the
op-based wavelet's data in a particular way.
And so events that pop out of here might be,
you know, a new line was added to the conversation
document and that sends in to--oh, a new blip
was added to the conversation. It's an abstract--abstract
event. So programmatic mutation, you know,
up in the boot to this thread comes in to
the application model. It transforms into
something that applies to the wavelet. You
interpret that as a wavelet mutation. Apply
that to its own data and sends the op off.
If someone else and some other client does
the same thing the op comes in here, applies
here, then the op-based wavelet and then the
application model both watched the events
from their trials and you update their own--in
memory state accordingly. So it actually turns
out to be very important to the building of
application models. It's just one event stream
up here and all the sort of local state update
is done in response to those events, so you
only have to write the code once to respond
to something lacking and you're blip being
added. It's not different whether you added
a blip or someone else added a blip, it's
just a new blip that was added. There's a
question.
>> So if you have three instances, how do
you end op-based condition from two people
actively editing [INDISTINCT] as soon you
get simultaneous ops coming in?
>> NORTH: So that's resolved by the server.
So, whenever--every operation that any client
generates is sent to the Wave server for that
wavelet. They reach the servelet in--they
reach the server in some order. The server
picks an order. You know, they get there in
some order. Whichever one gets their first,
goes first, whichever one gets their second,
goes second, and then they come out of the
server in that order. And so every--everyone
watching sees them in one particular order.
The two clients who are actually part of the
mutation, it's the operational transform code
that resolves the fact that they--their local
state mutated at the same time as the servers
canonical state. The operational transform
code, which I'm not going to go into too much
detail to, but I can point you to other talks
that do, transforms the operations at both
ends so that the intent is preserved. So if
you're--someone inserts some texts and someone
deletes some texts earlier in the document,
you know, the insert location moves back a
bit in the transform operation. It's the server
that the--it's the operational transform code
that computes that and resolves it at both
ends.
>> So that one of your purpose in the diagram
is actually the more ops that's been passed
through the multiple [INDISTINCT]?
>> NORTH: Yes, yes, yes, so that--yeah, good
point. So this--they might have been--they
saw that popped out of here, some op was already
coming in here. It's gone through the concurrency
control stack and being transform against
this one and will now apply correctly to the
document's state.
>> So, okay, if we can take this [INDISTINCT]
but I want to pick out the ops that are coming
over my generation.
>> NORTH: Uh-hmm.
>> It could be--how do you ensure that it's
not pushed through the [INDISTINCT] after
it's been handed off to concurrency controls
so the ops that are coming in the other direction
transform the code right up?
>> NORTH: I'm not sure. So essentially--the--these
arrows--ignoring the remote op arrow, these
arrows are synchronous. So, this whole flow
happens every time you push a key. And so
it's a--including the things enough to transform.
>> So you really don't have to worry about
concurrency?
>> NORTH: So, this is not--it's not concurrent
in the multi-threaded sense inside any one
client, so you don't have to worry about it
too much. The CC stack.
>> So I only have to worry about one op as
I'm passing through this [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Yes, that's right. Apparently, the
next one is my last slide--oh, that's right.
Okay, so building up now the top of our bottom
up talk. This is kind of an overview of the
whole--the platform and how we think about
the way the wave models supports Wave. So
the very core here we have--what I've been
describing. The Wave--the data, the core data
model and the concurrency control and operational
transform that allow it to be live in real
time. Then on top of that, we have things
like the robot library which sort of interface
with robots and then various features to the
client, like the editor, which is, you know,
the way that we let humans interact in real
time with these documents and can embed gadgets
and so on. So this platform is what we can
build applications on. The platform is built
up at the core. And then application, the
most well known application or application
components is, you know, Google Wave or the
Wave in a Box client. But other application
components can be built on top of this platform.
So attachments and robots, the actual robots
and so on, use this core to have their own
real time concurrent behavior. Over in the
client various things we mentioned, we were
supported by waves before so profiles were
represented in a wave in Google Wave. We haven't,
you know, done that in Wave in a Box yet.
Settings was a wave, gadget state is stored
in a wave, inside wave documents. The wave
panel is part of the application for, you
know, rendering a wave to you. And over on
this side to link and spell your application
components that worked well with conversational
wavelets.
Yes, question?
>> What is the measure [INDISTINCT], did the
editor seems to [INDISTINCT] the application?
>> NORTH: Yeah, I guess that's a good arbitrary.
You could build other Wave clients but you'd
still want the editor. Although, I guess it
depends on what platform you're building in,
that is somewhat arbitrary. We think of it
a reasonable component. It's self-contained,
you could--you could stick the editor and
all the non-Wave applications and it's good
for that too. Of course, that's why we think
of it as part of the platform.
>> Is the editor granular enough that if I
was checking and I want to go back [INDISTINCT]
the editor just to edit and check the annotation
[INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Excuse me. Yeah, I believe, sir.
I mean, it's probably a bit heavyweight for
that example but it would be capable of it.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: Please.
>> [INDISTINCT] So this--this diagram was
something we drew when we had a bit of a crisis
about how to model certain things.
>> NORTH: Actuate a little bit in case [INDISTINCT].
>> Okay, if we--it still looks good and they
supports the point I'd like to make. And so
we found out that the--we've constructing
the--managing the complexity of all this.
And then that--and then we came up with this
diagram to--and decided that a good way to
manage the complexity both in terms of sort
of the understanding and discussing the concepts
and also in terms of implementation was layering.
And there--so some of the most subtle and
finicky stuff is things to do with operational
transformation and the CC, Concurrency Control
logic, and so we wanted to not let application
stuff sort of seep in there. So we've spent--since
we drew this diagram two years ago, we spent
all that time trying to take things out of
the core and simplifying it, removing operations
and the--and the--so the--simplify the API
down here. And so the reason why I bring it
up was that both of them--this is a part of
the story of this diagram that's we found
was a useful lesson we learned but also to
understand them. When we discuss on the--there've
been discussions on the main list, and I hope
we'll have a lot of discussions this week
about what we can do with Wave and what we
should add and what we should change, that
we are--what we learned is that you should
not put extra features in here. You should--you
make sure that these things are simple and
that the--that they support building concepts
and applications on top of them. So, it's
a--we're very curious about what the--of what
we call the core. So, I imagine that that
will come up.
>> NORTH: Yeah, thank you, [INDISTINCT]. So,
wait--I mean, I'll go, and we've been moderately
successful as to build a core that supports
many types of application models and allows
them to take advantage of being real time
and have concurrency result naturally for
them. And so, yes, some of us feel very strongly
about the simplicity of that core. I'm sure
that will come out in various discussions.
So that's all I had. Are there more questions
before I sort of finish? I think we have a
beak next anyway, but are there more questions?
Okay, looks like my voice is just about held
out. So lets go and have some tea and coffee
and then chat.
>> We'll have a 10 minute break to grab some
chocolate or whatever.
ng real time and have concurrency res